I know you have a twin brother did you
ever do the thing where you switch
places he was having trouble passing he
was actually not going to graduate he
goes hey do you know a a Greek monologue
number yeah of course I just been doing
this for four years he goes listen I
need you to come down to my university
the room is 401 just could find a place
to sit so I make it to the lecture hall
she pulls me in the class she goes hey
are you ready to do this I go yeah seize
the moment I'm really starting to
appreciate having the audience and I get
a few Applause people dig it and I think
she starts looking at me kind of
accusatorily like
come over here
and she opens the door and takes me
outside and she goes when did you learn
how to do all of that
um it's just a hobby
she goes what can you stay and do this
for my next class I said uh did I get
the points and she goes yeah you got the
point my car's parked in the red I gotta
go